do not defamed do not be sarcastic don't
call each other with nicknames yeah he
lives in harmony or you believe avoid
suspicion
for suspicion in many cases of the same
do not spy on one another neither speak
ill about people behind the back that
means don't back bite are you ready to
eat the flesh of your dead brother the
holy quran says that if you bag bite it
is as though you're eating the flesh of
your dead brother because eating the
flesh of your dead brother is double
crime eating flesh of a human being is a
sin even the cannibals who eat human
beings they don't eat the meat of their
own brother so the holy quran says if
you bag by it you are doing double sin
it is as though you are eating the flesh
of your dead brother
speaking ill about someone without proof
is a sin speaking ill about someone
behind the back is double sin and Allah
subhana Allah says and give the answer
may you read about it the Salah
it increases truthfulness and honesty in
the business and the daily dealings as I
said earlier the Quran phase-in firaon
kabul chapter 29 was known 45 who to
nuuma Ohia la commune al-kitabi well
Akemi salata in no salata tan huh an
aphasia evil moon card that recite of
what we have revealed to do of the
inspiration of the book and establish
regular players for wearily players
restrained you from shameful and unjust
did the Holy Quran says in Ferrara
chapter 17 was number 81
what will jaha Circle battle in the la
batalla con azúcar say truly truth has
arrived and falsehood perished for
verily falsehood is by its nature bound
to perish salah teaches us that we
should be truthful a similar message
repeated
in surah Baqarah chapter 2 verse number
42 and 43 that cover not the truth with
falsehood nor conceal the truth when you
know it the Quran teaches us to be
truthful to always be truthful the holy
quran says in surah Baqarah chapter 2
was not 188 that eat up not your wealth
on vanities
so that you may use it as a bait for the
judges to eat up little bit of somebody
else's property knowingly or unknowingly
the Holy Quran says that bribing is
forbidden you should not drive it gives
us a way how to lead a truthful life the
Holy Quran it brings a person in a piece
at the faith in free Road chapter 13
verse number 28 that - verily in the
remembrance of Allah hearts do find
peace and tranquility is when you
remember Allah when you offer Salah you
have a peaceful life you are quiet
tranquility it is the best way of
communicating with Allah subhana WA
Ta'ala and the Quran says in surah
al-baqarah kappa - worse than 153 ya
ayyuhal Devine our MINUSTAH yo Mistah
brevis Allah or you who believe
seek a lot help with patient
perseverance and prayers in nala hama
sabrine for verily allah is with those
who patiently persevere Allah says in la
Hama sabrine for wearily Allah is the
told who patiently persevere besides
the social benefits the spiritual
benefits and the other benefits in Salah
we also acquire physical and medical
benefits in Salah when we do ruku that
is powered on extra blood flows into the
upper part of the body the spine becomes
supple the spinal nerves are nourished
it relieves back ache and pain it's a
good posture for flatter limbs when we
come back to the Urraco position that is
after ruku when we stand up the blood
which has entered in the upper part of
the body comes back to normalcy and the
body is relaxed when you do so dude we
put our forehead on the ground it's the
best position of Salah it is the most
important part of Salah daily the human
beings are propounded by electrostatic
charges from that Messiah which gets
precipitated in the central nervous
system which gets supersaturated these
extra electrostatic charges have to be
dissipated and discharged otherwise you
will have headache neck ache muscle
spasms etcetera no wonder people
regularly take tranquilizers and drugs
to leave the pain these extra
electrostatic charges have to be
dissipated and discharged for example
how do you have a heavy electric
appliance it normally has a three-pin
plug the third pin and the third wire is
for grounding for other thing similarly
they will do sujood we put the forehead
on the ground and the best part of the
body the brain and the best part of the
brain the frontal lobe is put on the
ground which causes grounding or
discharging of these extra electrostatic
charges that does not mean that if you
put your hand below the
ah the primary got a shock but there is
dominance on the frontal lobe and the
thinking capacity of the brain is not on
the top of the brain it is in the
frontal lobe therefore we do salute
insula then we do such that there is
extra blood supply going to the brain
which is responsible for a healthy brain
well do salud extra blood flows into the
skin of the face and the neck which
increases the blood circulation of the
skin of the face which is very healthy
especially in cold seasons it prevents
diseases such as fibrous itis and chill
beans where you do su dude there is
drainage of the paranasal sinuses and
there is less chances you have sinusitis
there is inflammation of the sinuses
normally the human beings throughout the
day they have an erect posture and the
maxillary sinus the Austrian the opening
is in the upper medial part and the
secretions because of the erect posture
cannot be drained therefore into dude
it's like inverting a pot which is full
it causes drainage of the maxillary
sinus it also causes drainage of the
secretion of the frontal sinus the
smaller sinus and the spoon on the sinus
and there's less chances the person will
have sinusitis or if he's suffering from
sinusitis it's a natural treatment
sujood is also a natural treatment for a
person suffering from bronchiectasis
which causes drainage of the secretions
of the bronchial tree it prevents the
accumulation of the secretion in the
bronchial tree it's also helpful in
other pulmonary diseases in which
secretions are cumulative besides
secretions other things like dust and
bacteria can also accumulate it's
helpful in all these diseases normally
when you breathe only 2/3 of your lung
capacity is utilized the remaining 1/3
of the lung the air remains
only 2/3 air comes in as fresh air and
goes out the one third air is called as
risperdal air when you do su dude the
abdominal viscera they press against the
diaphragm and the diaphragm it presses
against the lower lobe of the lung which
causes exhaling of even this residual
air so once the resin layer goes out
more fresh air comes in which is
responsible for a healthy lung way to
soothe due to decrease the gravitational
force the extra venous return from the
abdominal organs the various return of
the abdominal organ it increases the
sujud and ruku it's a good posture
against femoral and it's a fatal hernia
it's also a prophylaxis treatment in a
person suffering from hemorrhoids which
in layman's term knowledge is called as
piles it's also helpful in the prolapse
of the uterus way to sujood your weight
is concentrated on the knees when your
legs are flexed and the soleus and the
gastronomist muscles the muscles of the
leg are also called the peripheral heart
because it has an extensive various
return which is responsible for
increasing the vainest return of the
lower half of the body and it also
causes the relaxation of the lower half
of the body well do sujood your knees
are touching on the floor including your
hands and your forehead this posture is
helpful in disease of the cervical spine
because it is helpful in the
intervertebral joints the posture of the
sudoeste is also helpful in cardiac
diseases when a person rises from food
in the just opposition in the squatting
position the blood which has flowed in
the upper part of the body comes back to
normalcy and his body is relaxed there's
extra blood flowing in the muscles and
nerves of the tire in the back the back
muscles are relaxed it's useful and
helpful in constipation and in magician
it's helpful in a person suffering from
peptic ulcer and other stomach ailments
when a person gets up from the squatting
position to the cam position to the
standing position his weight is
concentrated on the ball of the feet
which improves the strength of the back
muscles high muscle knee muscle and leg
muscle there are various benefits
physical and medical
then we offer Salah but we Muslims we
don't offer Salah for these medical
benefits these only side dishes
we offer Salah to pray the last one out
Allah to thank him we offer Salah for
guidance to be programmed towards
righteousness these side dishes the
medical benefits mailtraq a person who
has less faith or may I take a
non-believer but we Muslims our main
course is to please Allah subhana Allah
because it's a commandment of Allah
subhana Allah
this is a biryani there are some people
who may ask that we see a few Muslims
who offers Allah five times a day but
yet they cheat they are not honest they
unrighteous people
so how come when you say Salah is a
programming towards righteousness
few Muslims will no offer 5 times Allah
very regular but yet they are not
righteous the answer to this question
was given by the car in the beginning of
a talk and recited verses from surah al
Mamoon chapter 23 verse number 1 & 2
which says cut a flaw al Mamoon
I'll live in a home feast a lot to him
she own indeed successful other
believers
those who pray with humility and
attentiveness Arabic word Hoshi own is
derived from cashews which means
humility and attentiveness so Allah says
all those who offer Salah with
attentiveness and humility they will
indeed be successful they will derive
the benefits but all those who only pray
outwardly without humility and
attentiveness they will not derive the
benefits of Salah so these few Muslims
who offers Allah and do not derive the
benefits and are not righteous it is
because they only offer the Salah
outwardly without humility and
attentiveness and for a person to be
attentive but naturally you should know
the meaning of what is offering the
Salah and you should follow the
commandments what Allah subhana Allah
gives for example in the Salah if the
Imam after surah fatiha recites for a
class and says hua hua had say he's a
loved one and only all the Muslims who
come to the mosque to offer Salah they
agree that Allah is one and only no one
says there is more than one Allah who is
the Imam giving guidance to what the
Imam is doing he's conveying the message
of allah subhana wa ta'ala to the muslim
man saying all who Allahu Ahad see he's
11 only go and tell to those people who
do not believe in Allah subhana WA
Ta'ala who do not believe a live one go
and tell them that hey there is Allah
one and only so the Imam is telling the
Muslims go out and tell to the other
people who do not believe Allah is one
that allah subhana wa ta'ala is one and
only and describe to them the concept of
allah subhana wa ta'ala many muslims
offer salah but when they immediately
finish the salah the message what they
received in the Salah has no
impact on the life at all and the main
reason is because they have not
understood the message so if you don't
understand the message how will you
implement it you have to follow the
commandments of allah subhanaw taala
in order to derive the benefits of the
Salah for example if you have a servant
who is very punctual who's very regular
in coming to work and he comes to the
office and he praises you but when you
give him any work or ask him to even get
a glass of water
he continuous bathing you but does not
get the glass of water you ring the bell
and your servant comes running to you
yes master
when you tell him that this is an
important urgent letter please deliver
to my client it's very urgent
your servant stays in the office and
continue saying I am obedient to my
master my master is great what will you
do
will it give you a promotion will you
give him a bonus we'll kick him out of
the job similarly it is a duty that the
servants of allah subhana wa ta'ala the
human beings we should follow the
commandments of Allah subhana Allah
only by offering praises it's not
sufficient for example a sick man he
goes to a doctor and the doctor gives
him a prescription and he writes in it
that you have to take the following
tablets thrice a day the patient takes
the prescription and religiously very
dedicatedly
he reads the prescription thrice a day
but does not implement on the message of
the prescription he does not take the
tablets do you think he'll be cured of
his sickness so in order to derive the
benefit of the Salah you should even
follow the commandments which we get in
the Salah that's the reason there are
few people who offer Salah but do not
get the benefit of the Salah and Allah
subhana Allah describes a few of the
people's infra my own chapter 107 verse
number four to seven which says for my
little mousseline elders in whom and
salute him Sehun unless in whom your own
my own own and my own that woe to the
worshippers those who are neglectful of
the prayers who only pray to be seen of
men but do not even provide neighborly
needs with such people the holy quran
says only prayed to be seen of men
woe to them curse them the holy quran
feelings for Anissa chapter 4 was not
142 that the hypocrites when they stand
in players they do not stand with
earnestness the only pray to be seen of
men and little do they have a line
remembrance Allah says there are people
are hypocrites who only pray to be seen
of men but do not pray with earnestness
neither remember last one out Allah in
the Salah every Muslim it is compulsory
that he should offer Salah five times a
day there is no option even when he's
traveling he should offer Salah but
there are certain concessions given by
allah subhanaw taala
and allah says in surah nisa chapter
four verse nine and one that when you
travel in the earth there is no blame on
you if you shorten your salah when
you're traveling you can shorten the for
rakaats
of zohar asara and and the last Isha's
allah - two Rakas you can even combine
the Zohar and Oskar Sala as well as
combine the Maghrib and Isha Salah it's
the concession given to you there is no
excuse for you not to pray even in the
battlefield you have to offer Salah and
I love subhana Allah gives the guidance
how Allah should be offered in the
battlefield the holy quran haven for any
such a performer 702 that oh prophet
when thou standeth for salah in the
battlefield take one party of the men to
stand with you for Salah
along with the arms and when they finish
the Salah let them go behind and
as the other party to offer Salah but
you can have the arms in your hand when
you offering Salah holy quran says infra
baccara chapter 2
what's the matter 39 that if you fear
any danger or any enemy
you can even prey on the foot or while
riding but when you and security
celebrate the praises of Allah subhana
WA Ta'ala as he has taught you the Holy
Quran says that offering Salah is
compulsory irrespective you're at war in
danger and the Quran says in surah nisa
perforce 103 that offered the Salah
standing or sitting or line but when
you're free from danger offered in the
regular manner in the battlefield
if you fear there's danger or any other
danger
you can offer Salah even by standing or
sitting or lying on your side's even if
you are sick all you can say this
William Rand chapter 3 was not 191 that
the believers offered the Salah standing
sitting or lying on the sides and
mentioned in say bihari and the
translation of Sai Bihari has got nine
volume this is the first volume and
mentioned in say Bihari wrong number two
in the book of toxiel chapter number 19
how did number 218 that a person
approached the prophet and said he was
suffering from hemorrhoids piles
how we perform the salah the Prophet
said pray while standing if you can't do
it pray while sitting if you can't do it
pretty while lying on your side even if
you are sick you have no excuse for
missing your Salah if you can't stand
real while sitting if you can't sit free
while lying on your sides you can even
pray with ishara with just indication
but offering Salah is compulsory
there is no excuse for you to miss your
Salah the Holy Quran says and so am i
that sacrifice was not fifty five that
your true friends are no less than allah
his messenger and the believers who
offer their Salah who practise regular
charity and who humble themselves its
mention abou the hood this is Abu Daoud
Abu Daoud has got three volumes it's
mentioned about the old one number one
in the book of salah chap number 300
hadith number 863 the Prophet said that
the first thing apostle will be asked to
account amongst all his actions on the
day of judgment essa la with the first
thing Allah subhana WA Ta'ala will
enquire you is regarding Salah and the
Holy Prophet said if mentioned say
Muslim this is a Muslim few people may
have the translation it's all been
higher if this is say Muslim it's
mentioned in say Muslim one number one
say Muslim consists of homeless or the
first volume mentioned volume number one
and the book of faith chapter number 36
husband 146 that the difference between
a man and the difference between a
mushrik polytheist and kaffir an
unbeliever is the negligence of Salah
it's mentioned up without one number
three in the katha Mehsana chap number
one six nine one hadith number four 661
it says that the difference between a
servant and a Kaffir unbeliever is the
abandonment of prayer means anyone who's
negligent of a Salah or abundance Allah
according to this Hadees he is
equivalent to a coffin
the holy quran phase in free mode hacer
chapter 74 verse number 41 43
ask the sinners that what led them into
the Hellfire
they will say we were not of those who
offered Salah we were not of those who
prayed
there's a beautiful du'a during the holy
quran in surah ibraheem chapter 14 verse
number 40 which says that o my lord make
me one who establishes regular prayers
and raise such people amongst my
offspring o my Lord grant me this favor
the door give me the holy quran in surah
al-baqarah chapter 2 verse number 201
which is a very famous du'a is Rob buona
mattina faith dunya has no town but will
accurately hasnot on what can either be
not that o my lord give me the good in
this world and the hereafter and save me
from the torment of hellfire I would
like to end my talk by giving the
Coalition of the Holy Quran in surah
al-anam chapter 6 162 153 which says
cool in NASA lot even uzuki mama Yama
Marty lillahi rabbil aalameen la sharika
lahu Abbas Allah , to a novel muslimeen
that say truly my prayers my service of
sacrifice my life and death is all for
Allah subhana WA Ta'ala the Cherisher of
this world he has no partner this I have
been commanded and I am of the first to
bow to his will
war Adama and reliable army
Jessica Milla Kyurem now we would have
the question and answer session to
derive more benefit for all present here
today in the limited time available if
you would like the following rules to be
observed during the question and answer
session questions asked should be on the
topic Sallah the programming towards
righteousness only questions not
relevant to the topic would not be
entertained kindly state your question
briefly and to the point only one
question at a time may be asked for your
second question you would have to line
up at the back of the row again and
await your second chance for asking a
question three mics have been provided
in the auditorium for the audience to
for the gents on my right and left and
one for the ladies at the back in the
center aisle please stand in a queue at
one of the mics if you wish to put
forward a question and speak into the
mic only when the mic is handed to you
by the mic handling assistance written
questions on slip papers would be given
secondary preference these slips are
available from a volunteers on the sides
kindly state your name and profession
before putting forward your question we
will allow one question only on each of
the mics in clockwise rotation maybe
have the first questions from the
sisters at the back I'm waheeda Khan I'm
doing my beard and I have done my MA my
question is why do the Muslims offer
Salah in Arabic when they do not
understand it will it not be preferable
to offer Salah in a local or a regional
language
the first ask was the question that when
most of the Muslims don't understand
Arabic won't it be preferable to offer
Salah in the local or regional languages
won't that be better sister if for the
sake of argument if I agree with you
that let's offer Salah in the local
language
so in Bombay there'll be few people will
say let's offer in English if you may
say or do if you may say Hindi some may
say Gujarati there will be an inviting
even if we come to a common opinion and
agree that lets say in Masjid number one
mosque one we offer Salah in English
mosque two in Urdu mosque three in Hindi
Moscow in Gujarati and so on and so
forth again there will be confusion and
fighting some may say that a Muslim
number one where you're offering Salah
in English we will follow the
translation of allama Abdullah Yusuf Ali
some may say we will follow translation
of picked on some may say Mawlana Abdul
Majeed area body others may say more sin
can again there'll be fighting even if
we agree that okay let's follow one
particular translation yet the
translation sister is a human handiwork
it cannot substitute the word of allah
subhana wa ta'ala or the word of the
Prophet and in translation they can be
mistakes and if there are mistakes this
mistake will be attributed to Allah
subhana Allah for example if you're
offering sarin Majid number two where
the offering in will do and suppose the
imam recites surah Luqman chapter 31
verse 34 and if you read the translation
most of the we'll do translations they
translate this was of the holy quran as
no one besides allah has the knowledge
of the sex of the child in the mother's
womb if you check the arabic text the
arabic word sex is not there in the
quran
it's the own interpretation of most of
the hoodoo translators and if a doctor
is offering Salah he will start thinking
that what kind of a prayer is this that
no one besides Allah knows the sex of
the child in the mother's womb
today we know Baltar sonography we can
very well and if a sex of the child he
will start doubting so therefore you
cannot read the translation because if
you read the translation and if you
commit any mistake the mistake will be
attributed to Allah subhana Allah
if it is a verse of the holy quran or to
prophet mohammed salah Salaam if it's
added and the translation cannot
complete the full meaning it can help
you in somewhat knowing the meaning to
help you to concentrate for example
since I'm a person who keep on traveling
if I go to France according to your
logic the Salah has to be offered in
French if the Salah has to be offered in
French but naturally even the iron
should be in French so if I go to France
and the gives the azan in French
I'll be wondering who is he cursing and
if I go to the mosque and attend the
Salah if we've been French I will wonder
whether the Imam he's praising Allah or
telling a story in French so if the
salah is in arabic
irrespective whether i as an indian who
don't know French or German if I go to
Germany or France or Spain or any part
of the world if I offer Salah I will at
least know what I am offering and I will
know its meaning and the Arabic Adan is
the international anthem of the Muslims
throughout the world international
anthem of the Muslim throughout the
world he may belong to anybody he may
belong to any part of the world he will
surely understand the meaning of that
Adan
it's an international anthem therefore
sister the best advice is that the
Muslims should learn the language of the
Holy Quran if we don't know Quranic
Arabic then we should at least know the
meaning the
translation in the language you
understand the best of those verses who
eat in the Holy Quran so that you will
be able to derive the benefits of the
Salah hope the answer the question next
question from the brother on the right
I'm graphic what concur business many
non-muslims alleged that Islam is
against idol worship where do the
muslims worship and bow down to the
kaaba in their prayers
that was the question that may
non-muslim knowledge that when Islam is
like an idol worship why do we bow down
to the Kaaba and why do we worship the
Kaaba indicating that we are the biggest
Idol worshipers we Muslims we bow down
towards the Kaaba the Kaaba is the Qibla
it's a direction we don't worship the
Kaaba we bow towards the Kaaba in a
Salah we only worship Allah subhana WA
Ta'ala and no one is v in Islam we
believe in unity suppose the Muslim want
to offer Salah here some may say let's
face not some method let's spits out
some method East amethyst we duration we
face so for unity all the people in the
world all the Muslim in the world they
have been commanded by Allah subhana WA
Ta'ala to face towards the Kaaba if you
are in the best you face towards the
east
if you are in the east you face towards
the west if you endure not towards the
south if you undersold towards the not
all Muslims face in one direction for
unity and the Muslims was the first
people who drew the world map and when
they do it they had the South Pole on
top and not fall down and alhamdulillah
the Kaaba the city of Mecca were in the
center the Westerners came and they
turned the map upside down and today we
have the North Pole on top and South
Pole down but yet Aram dual Allah the
Kaaba yet in the center
when we Muslims grow for height and men
retama we circumambulate around the
Kaaba we circumambulate to indicate that
every circle all the circles have only
one center to indicate that we worship
only one through our last one out
aligned awareness and the best answer
was given by hatha tomorrow may Allah be
pleased with him was the second Khalifa
of Islam
it's mentioned in cyber hari in volume
number 2 chap number 56 how did number
of 675 in the book of Hajj how that Omar
may Allah be pleased with him he said to
the black stone of Kaaba son guess what
he said that you are only a stone you
cannot harm me not benefit me had it not
been that I'd seen the Prophet kissing
and touching you I would not have kissed
or touched you
this hadith is sufficient to prove that
we Muslims we don't worship the Kaaba
and the best answer you can give is that
at the time of the Prophet there were
people who even stood on the Kaaba and
gave the Adhan I want to ask the
question which idol worship Oh will
stand on the idol he worships I am
shocked from my final year computer
engineering how will you reply to a
non-muslim who says that Allah is
nothing but another form of gymnastics
was a question but how do you reply to a
non-muslim who says that Salah is
nothing but another form of gymnastics
like what benefits they get they get
they also just a gymnastics you know
sending our bowing down going on etc
whether there's a world of a difference
between Salah and gymnastics in Salah
there is development of the body as well
as of the soul in gymnastics you made
error of the body but there's no
development of the soul in Salah you get
mental peace and tranquility
you don't get tranquility and mental
peace in gymnastics in the Salah the
movements are smooth without jerk in
gymnastics the movements of a judge
after Salah it removes your laziness
after gymnastics you get fatigued after
SLR you feel like working after
gymnastic movie attire don't be like
working Salah can be offered by people
of all the ages gymnastics cannot be
offered by people of all ages Salah is
absolutely free in gymnastics if you go
to a good team na jump you have to pay
through your noses in SOL I don't
require any equipment in gymnastics
require you know the parallel bars and
bring that cetera in the Salah the
social conditions improve the
improvement of the hood of unity of
solidarity in gymnastics there is no
improvement of social condition in the
Salah it guides you towards
righteousness it makes you a better
human being in gymnastics it doesn't
make you a better human being or it does
not improve your righteousness but the
main reason we offer Salah is to see the
pleasure of allah subhanaw taala
and Nia should be there even if someone
has a gymnastic exactly same posture as
the Salah it will not be equivalent
because in Salah we have the Nia the
intention to thank Allah Subhan Allah
Tala and think his pleasure which you
can never avoid in gymnastics alaikum
brother
why does Allah require us to praise Him
what benefit does he get the sister has
the question the divide of Allah subhana
WA Ta'ala required us to praise Him and
in what way does he benefit sister when
we play the last man o Allah or suppose
someone says Allah but Allah is the
greatest it doesn't make a lot more
greater Allah has already the greatest
whether you say Allah Akbar a million
times or whether you don't say Allah
will try to remain the greatest he's the
greatest and will remain the greatest
we pray Allah subhana WA Ta'ala not for
his benefit an answer is given and the
Holy Quran in surah fatah
chapter 35 verse 10 or 15 that we men
it is you who require Allah subhana
Allah it is you who want a last minute
allah allah subhan allah tala is free of
all wants worthy of all praises Allah
subhana WA Ta'ala does not require us to
praise him for his benefit he requires
us to praise him for our benefit because
but naturally we will follow the advice
of a person who's famous intelligent
popular and wife you will not follow the
advice of a person who's a stranger
unknown who's not intelligent who's not
wise therefore we praise Allah subhana
WA Ta'ala to satisfy ourselves that
allah subhana wa taala
is the most intelligent the most wise
the most greatest the supreme so that
indicating that we should follow his
commandments that the revenge that in
surah fatiha the opening chapter which
is always recite in the salah the first
four of five verses approving allah
subhanaw taala bismillah ar-rahman rahim
in the name of allah most gracious most
merciful al hamdulillah rabbul aalameen
praise be to Allah the Lord of the
Worlds al rahman al rahim most gracious
most merciful
yeah cannot do i yet understand the
alone we worship the alone we ask for
help we are praising allah subhana wa
ta'ala to convince us that he is the
greatest he is the only person who can
go for ultimate health and after this
then we decide the last few verses of
surah fatiha even a sirat al-mustaqim
throughout the lebanon am Tala him later
do be Allah him volleyball lean shows
the straight path the path of those who
have earned her favor and not of those
who go astray and not the path of those
which is rock
therefore we pray the last on earth
Allah to satisfy self that he is worth
asking for
is worth taking the advice off and then
we asked for help and advice for example
if a person has certain heart problem he
thick if a person who is unknown who is
a stranger we don't even know he comes
and give you advice will you take his
advice or will you take the advice our
person who you know is a very famous
heart specialist who advised me to take
but naturally will take the advice of a
person who the heart specialist who's a
doctor so therefore we pray the last
subhana WA Ta'ala to satisfy ourself for
our own benefit but irrespective however
much you praise Allah subhana Allah
it's not sufficient because the Holy
Quran say this forever 1/2 chapter 18
was the 109 that if the ocean was made
into ink to write the words of allah
subhanaw taala
the words of allah subhana wa ta'ala
will not exhaust even if you put to its
aid another ocean a similar message is
repeated and so look man chapter 31
verse 27 that if you convert all the
trees on the earth into pen and the
ocean back with seven ocean for supply
into ink to write the words of Allah
subhana Allah yet the words of allah
subhana wa ta'ala will not exhaust
however might you praise it is
insufficient but yet we pay the last man
out Allah and Allah requires us to
praise him not for his benefit but he
requires us to praise him for our
benefit so that we agree he is supreme
he's great he's intelligent is most wise
so that we can follow his Commandments
and stay on the serrata mustaqim the
true part my name is John um Robert
my question is what should I do if my
office timings do not permit me to pray
on time the better has a question that
what should he do if it office timings
do not permit him to pray on time
if you analyze the five daily Salah
which is the fun as far as the fajr
salah that the morning salah Decius
allah night salah these don't clash
normally with the office timings even
the Maghrib salah doesn't clash
welcome to zohar salah the afternoon
salah it can be prayed during the lunch
time
most often the lunch timing of the
office match with the zohar salah the
problem that arises mainly is in the
offer salah oh you may have difficulties
in other salah if you're doing a chip
etc but if you have problems if your
office timings are clashing with the
timings of the salah what you should do
is that you should request your employer
to give you a break of ten minutes to
offer your salah but most of the Muslims
we are afraid to ask I employer for time
of offering Salah but other things we
ask but when for picnic and going for
weddings and birthday party of you asked
but offering Salah we feel shy most of
the Muslims be apologetic we have an
affinity complex and your employer
even if he's a non-muslim my experience
tells me that 99 percent time he will
give you time off for Salah but you
should request his nicely humbly but
when he gives you time off there are
some Muslims who take a break for more
than an hour for Salah and they say they
have gone to a far-off mosque the
employer will start thinking that have
you gone for Salah why have you gone for
a stroll have got no objection a person
goes to pray in the masjid mosque if
it's close by if it's not close by or
will take a lot of time you can very
well even pray in the office you can
have a compact frame at a moussala and
keep in a lock-up as I mentioned my talk
our beloved prophet said it's mentioned
in Sai Bihari volume number one in the
book of salah chap number 56 habit
number 429 that the earth has been made
for me and my followers
as a Masjid at the place for doing free
dude therefore when the time for Pierre
is up you can pray you can even offer in
your office see to it that you find a
very clean place and you can offer Salah
don't pray extra nawafil etc pray or for
a Salah as well as soon at the maquis de
that is sufficient but there are some
people who when they go to office Allah
and if they find that picture is
obstructing them for Salah they take out
the picture or they cover the picture
with the cloth if the picture is
obstructing yourself ah three in head of
the room but he have to pray in the room
which has the picture
whenever the room then there are some
people who a non-muslim office they want
to make a Jamaat I have got no objection
if you meet at Ahmad but see to it that
all the Muslim employment office don't
leave the work simultaneously so that
the office becomes to a standstill
you can very well print several demas as
if you see it's mentioned sigh Bihari
I'm number one in hadith number six to
seven in the book of Adan chap number 35
it says that even a Jamaat can be made
by two people even two people are
suffering pajama so if you're working
all Muslim atmosphere don't put the
office work at standstill offering
varying demands and if a person if a
Muslim works dedicatedly honestly no
employer even if in the non-muslim will
prevent you from a break for offering
Salah if your employer is uncompromising
you can very well bargain with him and
tell him that okay I will not take my
tea break please give me break for
masala all you can say that if I take a
10 minutes break after off massage I
will have double I will work Tribble I
will work for half an hour free of
charge don't give me overtime any
businessman like yogi the person will
take ten minutes off and is working half
an extra after offices normally I have
to pay double or one and a half times
you tell him I will work thrice the time
of the break and don't give me a single
pipe even sure you agree
but an extreme case if your employer is
amongst the one person or uncompromising
at all the best option for you is
remaining is let me change the job
offering saliva if the employer is among
the one person who doesn't give you a
fossil I change the job you may never
know Allah subhana WA Ta'ala will give
you a job in which you may not know but
they respected whether you earn more or
less in the new job offering Salah will
gain you more benefit in the year after
than not offering and getting a few
hundred rupees more unfortunately even
in some of the Muslim offices which have
most of the employees in it Muslims
their own office Allah neither alone
neither in Jamaat I would like to
request all the Muslim brothers that in
the office they should see to it that
they themselves along with their
employees who are Muslims they should
offer Salah and there are always ways in
which you cannot disturb your office
work and yet office Allah in fact in the
long run if you are for Salah along with
the employees it will help you in your
business and you will make more profit
hope the answer the question